it has been hard
and i have made
the very hard and difficult decision to
not
be a part of real housewives of atlanta
season 13. nene leakes is in the middle
of an ugly and messy divorce from the
real housewives of atlanta and
she joins us now and nina i just want to
jump right in and set the record
straight
were you fired from the show
no what happened
i left the show i had an offer on the
table
i did not think the offer was a fair
offer i'm gonna tell you nene i've
talked to you a lot
i i've talked to you often and i i see
that
it feels like you know you are not your
usual self what's wrong
um it's it's it's fat
um it's unfortunate um
it doesn't have to be that way what
could have fixed it
um maybe maybe sitting down
behind the scenes having a conversation
maybe now there were comments asking why
did she say something to andy cohen
well i brought his name up because as
you know
i've done his show more times than he
has since i have been forced out of the
franchise
then leave my name alone
let me sit over here and heal in peace
okay
what happened with you and andy cohen
and why did things turn so
ugly what happened because you two had a
much better relationship before that
well i thought that we had a
relationship
uh and a great relationship uh but um
maybe we did i don't know how do you
feel about andy now
um you know you don't turn off your
feelings for someone because you had an
argument
i've always loved andy like he was a
family member of mine
i worked with him for a very long time
so i have a lot of love for him
um so you know you can't just turn your
feelings off because you had an argument
are you done with the housewives or
could you come back
um at this moment i'm not interested in
you know
being a part of real housewives i wish
them
all the best really i do but um
i don't think that's the place for me
you've spent so much time there you've
been such a big part of this franchise
it has been such a big part of your life
how do you go on and what's next
um you go on you know with healing over
time
do you think the show will be a success
without you i'm not trying to have an
argument
i hope so i would never wish anything
bad on them i mean that would not be
right
uh i would like to see the show continue
on and do well do you think
and and maybe you know the answer to
this but
do you feel like that if something could
have been worked out you could have
stayed with the housewives for years or
were they not respecting your position
as one of the
original housewives
no i i don't feel like you know i needed
to walk in and somebody needs to
respect my position kind of thing
absolutely not
that is not what this is about at all
and uh i would have loved to always be
able to play with them
i can't say that you know it's been a
lot of years and i i've grown in many
ways and it's just not something i
want to do you know every day
you said there were some truths you
wanted to talk about some of some truths
you wanted to tell
you wanted to get out there now that you
have moved away from the franchise
can you give us an idea of what you were
talking about
i can't um there are
legal people involved um so
you know hopefully these truths will
never have to come out
hopefully that we'll be able to work our
differences out quietly and
behind the scenes you're also upset with
wendy williams
nini likes attention dramatic attention
uh i don't know what nene's going to be
doing for money i'm not trying to count
coins but
you know the housewives is
that one thing that all the girls use to
promote their other stuff
she had that conversation with andy and
um
you then went on youtube and also on
twitter and
you said that a friend doesn't treat you
that way what did wendy do that really
upset you
um wendy talks about me every week
i mean i don't know why that wouldn't
have said anyone else i guess
maybe i'm different but she talks about
me every
week on her show or every month on her
show
then she went away and went on hiatus
while we were in this pandemic
she came back and since i announced my
exit she's talked about me on three
different occasions i mean
and she's only been back i think a week
maybe two weeks
if you could say something to wendy what
would you say to her
hey that's not a friend that would be
number one
and two i don't know why she
or anyone else think that it is okay
to go onto your national television show
and bash a person over and over
and over again now
maybe i'm a hot topic but every single
week or every month you need to be very
negative
towards me that does not feel good over
here
i am human and i deserve
more and better than that it's not right
to do that to somebody
every single week you wouldn't want that
done to you
it feels like i am being
devalued by
two people who seem to be intimidated
and that's not right
do you think andy's intimidated by you
also
you know that's almost a question did
you need to ask him
you ask him you know your name
brings attention clicks press
and controversy and do you think that's
the reason why they're using you they're
using your name
for publicity
good click it's a good clickbait i can
tell you that
my name is definitely a good clickbait
all right there's this other accusation
that surfaced on social media
and you kind of responded to it about
french montana that you would have
cheated on greg
with french montana that's right you was
all up under
french montana a whole married woman
nene first of all let's be clear
i'm a grown woman i'm not a kid
my husband and my family is very
important those
accusations i don't take lightly okay
french montana has
never in all of my years of knowing him
has never done anything to me other than
say hello
i mean he has never disrespected me we
are
not even close to being each other's
type
he's only been a fun person i've only
been in his company a very few too
few times and i think he's a great
looking guy
i think he's a great guy for someone he
is not a guy
for me and i got a lot of respect for
french he and i
don't have that kind of relationship
okay
we would never have that relationship
what do you want to do next
um you know i'm from the south okay
so i'm saying that to say i'm
superstitious
and uh whatever it is i'm going to do
next you would not know
today with me sitting here
i would not be telling you i hear you
call when you figure it out right you'll
call you'll let us know
well i just think that you don't speak
on things until
it's signed sealed and delivered but
there will be a next chapter for nene
oh i'm a survivor
[Music]
absolutely